I'm wondering at this point if we even
know who the enemy is we talk about
radical Islam or fundamentalist things
like that but who is it that poses the
most danger to the United States well it
was respect I think we have improved our
homeland security at his expense aware
FBI's now number one priority our toes
the community has has this number one
priority so I think in make major
respects we're a long way where we were
in 2002 2011 but the enemy now really is
a color a lot of jihadi ideology that
stems from the reason being is being the
sector's in Syria and elsewhere and most
it is not directly a source directly
directed the United States but there are
250 Americans who have gone over to
fight it's serious some of them will
come back do they come back as with
intent to harm still grips with his
anti-western jihadi philosophy craps the
other threat that extremely difficult
for law enforcement is itself
radicalized threat he has young people
on the internet seemingly fairly normal
it's suddenly over a month or two become
radicalized by the most sophisticated
Internet of communication system in the
world in the world the Islamic state has
developed and they're getting those
messages they may be troubled kids they
may be on the outside of other civil and
they get radicalized and they become as
you see they become a proper sandy
Berger the former national security
adviser to President Bill Clinton